les derniers mois ont été longs et
douloureux pour stéphanie tonnes
les souvenirs le sourire et la voix de
son fils nicolas la suivre partout c'est
lui qui nous aident à continuer et ses
images de l'accident qui l'a tué en
février 2014 la hante toujours une
collision d'une rare violence dans un
quartier pourtant si paisible cette
scène désolante est désormais considérée
comme une scène de crime
mon fils est parti alors pour moi ça
répare pas grand chose et à faire passer
mais au moins je le fais le déroulement
qui fait un dénouement exceptionnel le
policier qui a percuté la voiture qui
transportait le petit nicolas sera
finalement accusé au criminel de
conduite dangereuse ayant causé la mort
pourtant il ya six mois
le directeur des poursuites criminelles
et pénales avait clairement conclu après
enquête qu'aucune accusation était
justifiée dans cette affaire il y avait
main durant une conférence de presse
remis en cause la conduite du père de
famille le véhicule qui a selon la
preuve au dossier s'est engagé dans
l'intersection alors qu'il n'avait pas
de feux prioritaires dans une manoeuvre
qui n'était pas sans risques la décision
avait suscité l'indignation et soulever
des questions troublantes
pourquoi un policier de la sûreté du
québec rouler à 122 km heure dans une
zone de 50 à 8 heures du matin sans
sirène et gyrophare pourquoi si vite
alors qu'il ne répondait pas un appel
d'urgence mais plutôt suivait un suspect
dans le cadre d'une enquête de l'upac
une enquête indépendante a trouvé les
réponses et ses réponses feront
désormais partie de la preuve est encore
une grosse cheminement à faire
jusqu'au temps qu'on arrête pas là
ministre de la justice qui avait ordonné
cette révision réitère aujourd'hui sa
confiance au système
le député péquiste alexandre cloutier
croit que cette confiance dépend d'une
chose et c'est davantage de transparence
comment se fait-il qu'elle sera repris
des parents qui auront dit se battre
avec le système pour que finalement la
décision du dpcp soient revus pour les
parents du petit nicolas nombreuses sont
les leçons à tirer de leur triste
histoire
la décision du la mer n'est ni le
soulagement
ni une victoire la seule chose qu'on
peut demander ses choeurs ont fait ça
avec une certaine dignité ou en fils
amaral des restos radio canada montréal
on va poursuivre avec isabel richer
isabelle on le disait c'est vraiment
rarissime là comme décision ah oui c'est
exceptionnel c'est l'une parce que les
procureurs ils ont toute discrétion
toute la latitude pour porter des
accusations
selon l'évaluation l'analyse qui font
eux mêmes de la preuve alors ensuite on
peut pas leur reprocher d'avoir mal
évalué la preuve mais parce que si on
peut dire qu'il ya eu une gestion
malheureuse à ce que j'oserais dire
peut-être complaisante du dossier de
sorte que sa force et la reprise de
l'enquète par un comité spécial qui
était mise en place et qui visiblement
est arrivé à d'autres résultats donc le
dpcp disait on ne peut pas porter
d'accusations en lien avec la vitesse
excessive si ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
pourtant alors pourquoi est-ce que ça
passe comment expliquer que ça me passe
le test je soumettrai précis et vous
aussi sûrement de cette conférence de
presse où on disait la seule vitesse
excessive ne peut pas soutenir une
accusation de conduite dangereuse
causant la mort il n'y a pas longtemps
il ya un mois ces lignes j'ai couvert un
procès où une jeune fille a été accusé
de conduite dangereuse alors plaidé
coupable alors qu'elle roule à 90 dans
une zone de cinq ans et c'était la seule
manoeuvre qu'elle avait fait alors
visiblement ça dépend de la façon dont
on envisage les choses et les procureurs
qui analysent un dossier tout est
question d'interprétation de convictions
morales qu'on va pouvoir démontrer par
exemple que la conduite était tellement
déraisonnable qu'elle constitue un crime
il visiblement on a trouvé des nouveaux
éléments qui ont fait en sorte qu'un
procureur a même pas être convaincue
qu'il s'agit d'un crime et on a porté
une accusation mais tout cela démontre
bien sur l'urgence de mettre en place un
bureau d' enquête indépendante
oui en effet bureau d' enquête
indépendante que les gens ont réclamé
haut et fort parce qu'ils n'avaient plus
confiance dans ce processus qui fait que
ce sont des policiers qui enquêtent sur
des policiers même si c'est pas le même
corps de police les gens font pas
tellement confiance quand il ya des
bavures policières qui surviennent mais
ce bureau il est en train d'être
constituée on est en train de choisir le
présentement les dix huit enquêteurs
enquêteuse qui vont désormais se pencher
sur ces dossiers là et alors ça devrait
être fonctionnel d'ici la fin de l'année
2015 quelque chose qu'on attend depuis
longtemps un exercice beaucoup isabelle
je vous en prie